[MUSIC]
Personnel economics is the application
of economic principles,
statistics, economic theory, mathematics,
even, to questions that were
traditional human resource questions.
So questions that people would not
normally think of as lending themselves
easily to economics, motivating workers,
hierarchical kinds of questions, how much
authority should you give to your workers?
Those issues that were traditional in
human resources were dealt with in
quite a different way.
So if you think about organizational
behavior, which is another field in our
business school and in most business
schools, they think of it more from
the psychology point of view or
sometimes sociology point of view.
Whereas I deal with it, and to be honest,
I would say a harder-nosed way,
more mathematical, more statistical way.
And that's what personnel
economics is about.
[MUSIC]
If you look across countries, and
you say, in which countries have
workers enjoyed the highest wage gains,
say, over the past 15 years?
And then you say,
in which countries have workers been
most productive in the past 15 years,
what you'll find is that the correlation
between those two is very, very strong.
What that means is that if you go across
countries and you look at these countries
that are being effective in raising
worker productivity, are also the ones
where workers are seeing their wages grow,
so that's really important.
[MUSIC]
One of the most traditional
ways to motivate workers and
to increase both their productivity and
their earnings,
is to pay them something
that's called a peace rate.
Most of us are familiar with peace rates.
There are a couple of obvious examples.
Uber is a peace rate,
why is Uber a peace rate?
Well, because you basically get paid for
the number of rides that you give.
Depends on the amount of time
that you spend driving, but
more than that it depends on the actual
amount of miles that you drive.
And so they're paying you on
the basis of your output,
that's a very effective
way to motivate people.
And of course, if you look at Uber
drivers, they're pretty darn motivated.
They work pretty hard,
they work long hours.
They are very good at figuring out
the system, how best to get rides,
where to locate at certain points in time.
What does that for them,
the fact that they are directly paid on
the basis of their output,
so that's a great motivator.
[MUSIC]
How do you motivate people in situations
where output is difficult to measure?
Most of those kinds of
jobs are managerial jobs,
and managerial jobs are important for
the economy,
because they are the basis
of much of our productivity.
It's not just the workers, it's
the people who are managing the workers,
supervising them,
teaching them, guiding them.
How do you motivate the teachers and
the motivators?
Essentially what you have to do is,
you have to pay on the basis
of relative performance.
So something that i came up with
a long time ago, again, in my youth,
it's called tournament theory.
[MUSIC]
What tournament theory is about is, it's
kind of obvious when you think about it,
it's not very complicated, you kind of
wonder why no one thought about it before.
But it's basically the idea that
firms structure their compensation
in the same way that people run
tournaments, sports tournaments.
So for example, if you think about
Wimbledon, tennis match, and
you say, how does Wimbledon work?
Well, Wimbledon works by paying a prize
to the winner, and second place prize
to the loser of the finals, because that's
the second place person in the tournament.
The difference between
the winner's prize and
the losers prize serves to
motivate those players.
Now they would be motivated even if
they didn't have that prize, but
depending on the size of that prize,
they'll be motivated even more.
So for example, if there were a million
pounds at stake winning that tournament,
people would be highly motivated to play.
And that's what happens in business.
So what tournament theory talks about is,
first of all,
how to set up those implicit contests,
competition between these workers, do it
in a way that doesn't undermine the firm,
because sometimes competition can be bad.
They'll work to sabotage
one another essentially,
because they're trying to
get the next promotion.
And then finally to think about how big
a raise should you give those individuals
when they get promoted from one level to
another to both motivate them below and
then give them incentives above?
[MUSIC]
Another way that workers are sometimes
compensated is on the basis of the team,
why would you do that?
Well, sometimes people need to cooperate,
and in order to get them to cooperate,
you have to pay them on
the basis of their joint output,
not on the basis of
their individual output.
Let me give you an example.
There's a good example by one of my
colleagues here, Catherine Shah,
who with a couple of co-authors did
a very nice study of a firm in Brazil
that was actually a law firm.
And what they did was, they had initially
paid their lawyers on the basis of their
billings, straight on the on the number
of billings, that's a measure of output.
Sounds great, because you can easily
observe it, you basically know who's doing
what, you can motivate them very
effectively, but here's the problem.
Because they were being paid on the basis
of their own billings, the senior lawyers,
who had the ability to
allocate cases to one another,
took all the great cases for themselves,
even when they weren't necessarily
the best partner to handle the job.
And so what the firm did is, they said,
our junior people, some of whom
are highly qualified to be working on
these cases, are not getting the work,
because the senior guys
are taking it all for themselves.
What do we do?
We've gotta change the compensation
structure so that you're paid not only on
your own billings, but you're essentially
paid on the profitability of the firm.
Now, because you're paid on
the profitability of the whole firm or
of a sector of the firm, you care
not only about how well you do, but
you also care about how
well your coworkers do.
As a result, there was an enormous
transformation in the way that work was
allocated, and an enormous transformation
as well in the productivity of the firm.
So profits went up,
billings actually went up, and
the work was better handled and people
were much happier as a result of that.
[MUSIC]
Team compensation can be very effective.
One problem with team compensation
is it doesn't always work, why not?
There's something in economics
called the free rider problem,
I'm sure many of your listeners
have heard about that.
But the free rider problem comes about
when you have an incentive to shirk and
basically put the burden on someone else.
Some of your viewers may remember
when they were in school,
perhaps even at Stanford Business School,
although we don't have any shirkers here.
But if you're involved in a team project,
suppose five of you have
a homework assignment,
you have to get together and write up
the assignment for the whole team.
Sometimes one person will work
harder than another person, and
sometimes even a teammate might be
critical of the other teammate,
because of the behavior
of the other teammate,
not putting in the appropriate amount of
effort, the appropriate amount of time.
So the free rider effect comes about in
teams, and as the team size gets larger,
the free rider effect
becomes more pronounced.
Because your ability to affect the total
output of the team gets smaller and
smaller.
So team output,
team compensation can be affected
in a strong way as long as the teams
are structured appropriately.
First of all, you have to make
sure that the teams Involve
people who are highly
complimentary to one another.
So you want to make sure that
I'm working with someone whose
output will benefit greatly
from my input and vice versa.
You also want to make sure that
the team is small enough so
that we can observe each other,
we can monitor each other,
we can motivate each other, and
that's an important component as well.
So firms can use team compensation, but
they have to be pretty careful
about the way they set it up.
[MUSIC]
People often work for a long time in
a company, and the question is, what do
you do to motivate managers when they're
essentially done with a tournament?
What do I mean by done
with the tournament?
Look at me, I've been the equivalent of a
middle level manager for most of my life.
I'm a senior professor at Stanford,
but there's nowhere for me to go.
I have no aspirations to be a dean or
anything like that.
So how do you keep me motivated?
Well, again, there are ways that you can
do this that have to do with compensation
in addition to non-monetary forms, but let
me give you the one that's compensation.
So when I was a young guy, and I was
working really hard trying to get tenure,
at this point it was at
the University of Chicago.
And I was looking at my senior colleagues,
and while they were very smart and
very productive people, I still thought
that I was working a lot harder and
even more productive.
I wrote a lot of papers in those days,
I still try to write a lot of papers.
But when I was a young person,
I was probably better at it than I am now.
And yet I was paid a lot less than
my senior colleagues, and I thought,
why is that, isn't this kind of crazy?
I'm the guy doing all the work, and
they're the guys making all the money.
And so I thought about it and
I realized, well, actually,
that motivates me,
because what happens is, as a result of
seeing my senior colleagues make a lot of
money, I want to be a senior colleague.
And that was true throughout
most of my career.
So when I was in my 30s and 40s,
at that point I was already a tenured
professor with an endowed chair,
there was pretty much nowhere for
me to go in the tournament, but
I still cared a lot about being
successful in the organization.
Not only because I wanted Stanford to
succeed and I wanted myself to succeed,
but also because I wanted to
be well treated in my old age,
which I have now reached.
And I am well treated, and I think part
of that is because I try to continue
to be productive, but part of that is also
pay off for what I did as a younger man.
And that motivates the younger generation,
it motivates the 40 and 50 year olds, many
of whom are still very productive, and we
want to keep those people very productive.
By their ability to see how Stanford
treats me, they say, all right,
if I perform well, I understand
that someday I'll be like Lazear,
and maybe I'll be a little bit overpaid,
but it's okay,
it's compensation for
what I'm doing right now.
[MUSIC]